premier tech est un visage longue 22
minutes publié dimanche dernier par la
star de la pop britney spears sur sa
chaîne youtube entre un
message audio de la chanteuse dénonce
les treize années tutelle familiale
qu'elle a subis et qui ont détruit sa
vie
tutelle prisu décision de justice en
2008 et sous l'autorité de son père
jamie spears qu'elle décrit aujourd'hui
comme un tyran
apparemment tout le monde veut du mal à
britney
et bien c'est son ex compagnon kevin
federline qui a publié des vidéos
compromettantes de la chanteuse
notamment la vidéo d'une dispute entre
elle et ses deux fils sean et jayden
son ex-mari a d'ailleurs affirmé lors
d'une interview exclusive donnée au
daily mail que ses enfants ne souhaitait
pas revoir leur mère actuellement les
garçons ont décidé qu'ils ne la voyait
pas en ce moment cela fait quelques mois
qu'ils ne l'ont pas vu ils ont pris la
décision de ne pas aller à son mariage
kevin federline a aussi apporté son
soutien total au père de britney spears
j'ai vu un homme qui se souciait
vraiment de sa famille et qui voulait
que tout se passe bien quand j'ai mis à
prix la relève qui tu es rentré en ordre
il lui a sauvé la vie un nouveau coup
dur pour la star qui a décidé de quitter
installera pour se consacrer pleinement
à ses nouveaux projets artistiques
notamment avec elton john avec qui elle
vient de sortir un tout nouveau single
intitulé hold me closer
[Musique]
déjà numéro 1 des ventes sur itunes à
travers 40 pays dans le monde si britney
spears n'a pas encore fini avec ses
affaires familiales elle est bel et bien
de retour sur le devant de la scène
musicale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le titre qu'à la sortie parce ne restait
plus rien 60 millions d'euros elle a
quitté les réseaux sociaux elle était
vraiment dépressive elton john c'est son
pote et madonna aussi et c'est madonna
qui a appelé john et qu il écoute tu as
fait un truc super u de l'ipa va l'aider
tout ce que je vous raconte les vrais il
l'a appelée et lui a dit tu sais quoi tu
choisi la chanson tu choisis remake ste
le remix comme on va le faire tu fais ce
que tu veux et au moi je pose ma voix
dessus et on le fait et ça a donné ça
c'est premier single qu'elle sortait
depuis six ans ses premiers dans 40 pays
sa valeur lors la relance et un petit
alors je sais pas si vous aimez ou pas
sa [ __ ] et cinq jours avant tout les fan
fan fan de johnny qui est là-bas à petit
assistant qu'est la battère montre lui
les fans total s'affûter cinq jours
avant il était en crise crise angulaire
c'est incroyable vous aimez le titre ou
pas oui c'est une reprise de tiny dancer
une chanson d'elton john avec nos
remontées à des années moi je trouve ça
hyper efficace on entend les fans
chanter l info quand même oui mais ça
c'est classique on l'entend jamais
chanté sa voix assez basses à son arme
secrète on sait mais en tout cas c'est
quand même un million de streaming dès
le premier jour c'est quand même un bon
retour même si on dit qu'elle est un peu
fini l'est pas tant que ça c'est jean
sassus diot et avait été tabassé alors
avant de nous pas d'elton john donc il
ya une vidéo choc sur youtube où elle
apparaît sur youtube voilà je vous avoue
t elle elle a tout dit maintenant parce
que yo prendre une vraie qui veulent
inviter tous nos invités pour des sommes
d'argent indécent c'est ce qu elle dit
non non non moi je veux parler qu'à ma
famille mais c'est interdit roussineau
sur youtube je tout vous dire elle a
tout dit elle a tout balancé sur sa mère
notamment et sa soeur regarder
mais
[Musique]
ils ont tué un peu sa carrière ils ont
tué sa personnalité ils ont tué son fils
ils ont tous fait l'enfermer était dans
une cage dorée avait le droit de voir
personne rend compte qu'elle a même dit
que ces trois derniers disent que les
trois indices étaient pas le cacher son
l empêcher de retirer son stérilet pour
qu'elle tombe enceinte mais c'est quand
même affreux alors elle envoie à sa mère
surtout de ne rien avoir savait sa soeur
ouais mais c'est une hyper sensible je
pense que tout le monde a profité d'elle
à un moment donné je peux comprendre les
concevoir qu'elle est plus envie de
parler à personne d'autre mais ben ammar
sa femme et sa propre famille l'a trahi
et moi je comprends totalement ce qu'est
louis et je trouve ça lisieux risque
élevé oui c'est horrible je 13 ans peut
comprendre qu'elle ait pété un câble est
ce que vous savez je donnais la parole
pire du pire du pire ces enfants ne veut
plus la voir j'allais dire que vous
allez dire il va tu peux nous dire
pourquoi moi parce que il ils reviennent
sur les rapports exécrables qu'ils ont
eue avec avec ben voilà les gars ont
décidé à voir si en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que il ya un vrai vrai conflit
entre l'eulex federline britney est
aujourd'hui britney elle a été obligée
de répondre aux enfants en leur disant
qu en gros le pas le mec était incapable
qu'il n'avait jamais gagné sa vie qui
lui payait une pension qui les
surveillait pas pour les devoirs que il
était probablement très heureux de vivre
comme ça mais que c'était un peu tant
pis pour eux donc c'est des lettres
déchirantes qui sont envoyés les uns les
autres et il ya même pas vraiment de
raisons à ça c'est juste que c'est une
situation il ya un truc à elle c'est que
le kevin federline fait un truc vraiment
dégueulasse c'est quoi ce qui est des
raisons pour lesquelles il ne voulait
plus voir leur mère c'est toutes ses
photos et ses vidéos riz à moitié nue
complètement un peu dans le gaz non mais
il tient dans la hesse qui fait comme il
peut rien qu ils ne gagnent pas d'argent
sa fille à rien de gagner de l'argent
c'est de parler la presse people et il
sait qu'en balançant des choses du gaz
de l'argent donc les enfants entendre ça
et détestent leur mère oui mais mathieu
n'y a pas que ça soit fait hier britney
spears est revenu sur instagram son
compte avait été suspendue à la perche
derrière elle a remis à mme ri on a un
poste instagram où elle met tout un
texte où elle explique beaucoup de
choses elle parle principalement de son
ex kevin federline où finalement elles
l'accusent d'avoir finalement monter ses
enfants contre elle donc en fait elle
entre sa famille à son ex en gros elle
n'a que ses enfants au bout de la halle
l'aurait enlevée et le youtube à
l'enlever au bout de cinq heures et elle
laisse un truc 5h05 juin répondu à cette
vidéo qui avait sur youtube en lui
disant c'est pas clean ce que tu fais
bien on discute toutes les deux et c'est
ce qui est très drôle puisque la mère
avait quand même sortir un livre sur sa
fille
elle avait pas besoin de lui parler dans
les yeux voilà ce mot là qu'elle a mis
en lui disant arrête d'étaler notre vie
à tous bien on parle toutes les deux
comme une maman et sa fille et arrêts et
c'est juste à présent qu'elle a relevé
son club mais après c'est bien mais
c'est que les mac c'est l'écueil keane
pardon mais les geordies et c'est ce
genre là il est donc toutes ces femmes
et je lui fais part les ornements c'est
une vie c'est souvent le cas
malheureusement quand tu es en couple
avec quelqu'un qui a une notoriété en
dessous de la tienne et qui n'a pas la
même carrière que toi qu'ils utilisent
ça se sent après la séparation ils
utilisent et ça m'est arrivé aussi donc
je suis bien placé pour en parler c'est
souvent le cas qu'ils utilisent des
choix famille de tout du
mec soit tu fréquentes quelqu'un qui n'a
pas la notoriété pas les faits rien il
utilise sa contre toi et tes le stick
mais j'ai pas de notes